حكومه طالبان في افغانستان مقتل ثلاثه
مسلحين هاجموا فندقا بالعاصمه كابل
وقالت حكومه طالبان في بيان لها انه لا
يوجد قتلى في صفوف الاجانب المقيمين
بالفندق الذي يرتده عاده رجال اعمال
صينيون واكد مراسل العربيه ان الفندق الذي
شهد الهجوم يقع قرب القصر الرئاسي ومقرات
البعثات الدبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
متابعه لهذا الموضوع معي من كابل الان
مراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر عبد الله
اهلا وسهلا بك ملابسها هذا الهجوم ما الذي
كان يستهدفه تحديدا وهل تبنت اي جماعه
مسؤوليتها حتى الساعه
اولا ااا لم تتبنى اي اي جهه مسؤوليه هذه
العمليه وهذا الهجوم
ويبدو من ملابسات وحيثيات هذا الهجوم وهذه
العمليه ااه ان داعش ربما نفذ هذه العمليه
لان تم مقتل ثلاثه من المهاجين في
العمليات التصفيه التي نفذتها القوات
الافغانيه
واستمرت هذه العمليات والاشتباكات بين
الطرفين همم لساعات طويله وانتهى بمقتل
همم المهاجمين بحسب ذبيح الله مجاهد الذي
قال في تغريده بانها اعداء الاماره بحسب
تعبيره نفذ هذه العمليه
ويقصد باعداء الامارات داعش وداعش
كسفت عملياتها التفجيريه والدمويه في
العاصمه كابول وكذلك في بقيه المدن الكبرى
وبالتالي القراءات سياسيه والامنيه تقوم
بان داعش هو الذي نفذ هذه العمليه همم
عبد الله ما الذي كان يستهدفه الهجوم يعني
هل
الرعايه الصينيون الذين يرتدون هذا الفندق
كانوا هم المستهدفون من وراء هذا الهجوم
ام لا في مارب اخرى همم للمهاجمين
الصينيون المواطنين الصينيون كانوا ينزلون
في هذه في هذا الفندق بين حيل واخر والان
وصلتنا همم انباء للتبوي بان المستشارين
الصين كانوا قد نزلوا في هذا الفندق ومن
الممكن ان ااه العمليه التفجيريه استهدفت
المستشارين الصين والمواطنين الصين اذا
كنت اقول ان الصين في ال- في الامن
الاخيره ابرمت همم اتفاقيات اقتصاديه
واستثماريه هائله مع طالبان وهذه
الاتفاقيه اذا ما نفذت على الصيغه المبرمه
ربما ستضر على طالبان اموال همم باهظه فمن
الممكن ان
المستهدفين همم يعني ارادوا من هذه
العمليه الصرف الصيد من هذه المعاهدات
الاقتصاديه والاستثماريه مع طالبان بحسب
الذبيح الله مجاهد الذي اعترف بان الفندق
همم كان فيه اجانب ولم يصب احد من الاجانب
او لم يقتل احد من الاجانب الا
اجنبيين اصيب بعدما القيا بنفسيهما من
المنزل العلبي وهذا يعني ان في هذا الفندق
كان هناك اجانب صينيون طيب عبد الله لماذا
تبدو حركه طالبان عاجزه تماما عن وقف مثل
هكذا هجمات نحن نتحدث عن قلب العاصمه
كابول عن الشارع الذي فيه المقرات
الدبلوماسيه ومع ذلك هذه الهجمات تتكرر
لماذا تبدو حركه طالبان عاجزه عن وقتها
ولا تضع هذه الهجمات حركه الطالبان في
زاويه ضيقه
هذه الهجمات يبدو ان ان خلفها عقول مدبره
وان التكهن بها فضلا عن كشفها صعب جدا
وحركه طالبان يعني بين حين واخر تهاجم
معاقل لعناصر داعش والجماعات الاخرى التي
تصفها بانها اعداء الحكومه الحاليه ولكنها
لحد الان عجزت همم
تمنع ااا او
يعني تكون حيلوله همم دون هذه العمليات
التي تستهدف اماكن حساسه في قلب العاصمه
كابل وكذلك همم في قلب المدن الاخرى
الافغانيه مثل ما زارت فكانت هناك عمليات
دمويه استهدف همم يعني علماء الدين همم
كانوا موالينا لطالبان ومؤيدين لطالبان
طيب
يسالك هل من الممكن ان يكون وراء هذا الهج
او المنفذوه هذا الهجوم كانوا يريدون خطف
همم بعض المستشارين الصينيين من اجل الضغط
على الحكومه الصينيه بفديه او ما شابه
اما الخطف من هذه المنطقه الحساسه
والخاضعه لنقاط التفتيش المكثفه من قواته
وعناصر طالبان فمستحيل واما مقتل او
استهداف المستشارين الصين فهذا ممكن ومن
الممكن ان هذه العمليه والهجوم المسلح
استهدف المواطنين الصينيين بما فيهم
مستشارين الصين بحسب اخر تقارير وصلتنا من
هذا الفندق علما بان المنطقه والشوارع
المؤديه كلها مسدوده لحد الان وتقوم عاده
همم القوات الامنيه بمحوي اثار مثل هذه
العمليات التفجيريه والهجومات التي تستهدف
مناطق حساسه ويروح لها ضحايا مدنيون
وغيرهم علم بان همم مستشفى الطوارئ في
العاصمه الافغانيه كابو الامريكي قال انه
تم نقل 21 شخصا من المصابين وثلاثه من
القتنه وهؤلاء القتلى مواطنون افغان هذا
الفندق انا رايته ينزل فيه مواطنون افغان
وكذلك الاجانب بما فيهم الصينيون جاي من
كابول عبد الله نادر مراسل العربيه شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه